all right so you too I am obsessed with
this series I'm obsessed it's so fun
it's so full of heart I mean I know
people are freaking out because
obviously Modern Family days we're
seeing you two reunited Sarah what was
it like to reunite on set with Adam
oh it was a dream it was such a dream I
am such a fan of Adam not only his work
but also just as a human being and
um it's just it's great to do projects
with friends in general but um he's just
such an amazing Powerhouse of a talent
that it was it was just such a joy and
our chemistry is good right our
chemistry's good Adam okay yes quit
yelling our chemistry's good
uh I like that Brittany build us up
little ego absolutely listen I am only
going to Echo you your chemistry is
amazing on screen chef's kiss wow chefs
Chef skits I love it too I say all the
time that uh I feel like Sarah is like a
like a Sally Field or a Betty White or
someone that is just gonna have like 80
years of uh of a career under her belt
uh when she's an old woman and I'm happy
for you to just be like a small part
along the way
I loved that I love that okay true
friends over here right true friends I
love this
So Adam let me ask you because you've
been with bumper Allen for many years
like a decade to be exact yeah
and I mean when you were approached with
a series like this were you excited to
you know show another side of bumper
yeah I I mean it truly just like smacked
me across the face I had no idea that
that's what Elizabeth Banks was was
calling me about she was like hey do you
mind if I zoom with you and I'm like
sure uh and
how she pitched it she was like watching
Loki which they spin-off Marvel series
and she was like I it was so cool that
it was about the villain and you get to
tell the the villain story and I'm like
how does this apply to me uh and it's
the first time I really she was like you
were the villain of the Pitch Perfect
movies and I was like what
I guess Christmas or not
um so yeah so I just thought that was
kind of a cool way to to go into it and
you know I never really
I got to put closure to the character so
I wasn't in the third movie so like I
kind of was just hanging there and I
loved playing that character so much so
I was excited to come back and and uh
and put a little cherry on top of the
Pitch Perfect
that's awesome for myself
absolutely I mean it was really like a
Redemption story like always go after
your dreams right you could still pursue
them absolutely
okay so I have to ask you to this I mean
we're going out let's just say
hypothetically we're going out we're
hitting the town we're going to a
karaoke bar
what are you two getting up there and
singing
all day Atlantis all day
thanks Steve oh yeah uh I'm gonna do
something just easy acceptable uh
accessible for people to sing and I'll
go Mariah
yeah so easy to say something easy for
me to just grasp grab a hold of and just
belt Mariah or Celine totally totally
are we hitting the high notes we're
getting the range in there hey Brittany
you've seen the show I think you know
what I can do I can't even believe I
just asked that I mean honestly I know I
know you've got range
can't even hear it that's how hot can it
is so high the dogs are barking actually
[Laughter]
so listen I mean there were some amazing
people
um you know in the film I know there are
a lot of fan favorites from Pitch
Perfect can we expect any cameos blink
twice if yes
well uh flula is in the it was in the
second movie and he he is a large part
of this this series so uh yeah more than
a cameo you get you get a whole dang
character
awesome awesome well thank you two so
much for this I'm again congratulations
on this series it is awesome it is such
a feel-good thank you oh thank you